نحن الان نحاول الاصول الى كرب- قلبي
الدار البيضاء حيث ااه تتحرك الحشود
للاحتفال هذه ستكون ليله همم تاريخيه
للاستثنائيه فرحه علمت تنتشر في اكبر مدن
المغرب بهذا النصر التاريخي الذي حققه
المنتخب المغربي وهو يتاهل الى الدور
النصف النهائي من كاس العالم لاول مره في
تاريخ ولاول مره في تاريخ الرياضه
الافريقيه والعربيه
الفرحه لا تصف كانت هناك امال عريضه قبل
همم
في ان يتمكن المنتخب المغربي من الحفاظ
على المستوى الذي اظهره خلال مباريات كاس
العالم وان يستمر اللاعبون في تالقم وفي
المزيد همم من اسعادي المغاربه عبر حقيقي
المزيدي من الانتصارات الان ااا نستمع
الحركه صعبه همم هناك انتشار امني مكثف
الكثير من الشوارع اغلقت الكثيرون الان
يحاولون الاصول الى منطقه باب مراكش والى
شاطئ عين دياب
ستستمر الاحتفالات هذه الليله ستكون ليله
استثنائيه في المغرب وفي كل مكان نشاهد
احتفالات همم
مغربي
[موسيقى]